well you know it we're just days away
now from the new year and the las vegas
strip starting to get into the spirit of
things
resorts world on the north end is
lighting up a pretty massive display
arko mana joining us now live there with
a closer look at it now that the sun is
set oracle we can really see it there
behind you
that's right guys and 2020 has been a
really difficult year for so many people
and everyone needs just a little
positive energy as we head into the new
year
and that's exactly what this massive led
screen
here at resorts world hopes to give us
just take a look the display will be
shining bright on new year's eve
and it's quite the display resorts world
ceo scott sabella telling me
the led screen is 100 000 square feet
and it's really the perfect place to put
this message as we look forward to 2021.
to wish everybody happy new year on it
means a lot to us it's one of the
largest led screens you know in the
world
and that's just part of what resource
resort world has there's led inside the
building there's more going on the
outside of the building
that people haven't seen yet
resorts world really trying to get the
excitement going for
2021 this huge message will be visible
if you drive down the strip really
from a lot of places across the valley
and will be on full display on new
year's eve from 5 p.m to midnight
and continuing with this theme of
positivity sabella tells me
once resorts world opens next summer as
it's projected to he expects it
to help las vegas rebound after this
tough
economic year reporting live from
resorts world tonight orca mana 8 news
now